hello in this video we'll talk about the
blood brain barrier
we know that our brain is surrounded by
blood vessels which supply our brain
with oxygen and nutrients
blood brain barrier is a physical
barrier
between the brain
and the blood
there are cells and molecules which
forms this barrier and in this video
we'll look at this part in details but
let me tell you that blood brain barrier
prevents any random solutes or pathogen
in the circulating blood from entering
the brain
you might be thinking how this is useful
let me tell you that blood brain barrier
is a protective mechanism
that we have
in this video it would be really clear
so the blood-brain barrier restricts the
passage of pathogens
harmful metabolites toxins and large
hydrophilic molecules inside the brain
and thereby creating a selectivity
filter
now let us look at the blood brain
barrier from a different angle
here you can see
these are the capillary endothelial
cells which lines the capillary wall
these are the astrocytic end feet that
means these are the projections of the
astrocytes
and these are pericytes
all these
cellular components are really important
to understand the blood brain barrier
so now we are going to zoom
into one of these junction of the
capillary endothelial cells
now we can see there are several
junction molecules which are present in
between two capillary endothelial cells
there are a bunch of transporters which
are also present
blood brain barrier allows the diffusion
of oxygen and carbon dioxide some
hormones and polar molecules
now let us only focus on the capillary
endothelial cell and forget about the
astrocytic enzyme for a moment
so here we can see tide junction exists
between these endothelial cell and this
style junction is the key molecular
component of the blood-brain barrier
now there are several transporters which
are also present in the endothelial
cells which allows the transport of
important substances such as glucose to
the brain
other transporters can allow influx of
several ions inside the brain
now
let us try to understand
how this blood-brain barrier is
important for our brain the blood-brain
barrier restricts the passage of several
immune cells
antibodies and many other immune factors
such as cytokines and thereby preventing
our brain from harmful effects of immune
activation
so one can understand that brain is kind
of immune privileged
now let us zoom into the junction
between two capillary endothelial cell
and try to understand the selectivity
filter or the type junction in bit more
details so the type junction is formed
of two major proteins
occluding
and chlorine
there are many subtypes but we but we
are not going to get into that much
details
now these chlorine and occluding
proteins are crucial for this tight
junction formation this junction is so
tight that even water molecules or small
ions cannot pass through this
there are specific proteins such as zo1
and two which are zonular occludants
protein which associates with the
chlorine and occluding proteins
there are also another type of protein
which is known as junction associated
molecule or jam
these are also associated or found in
adhere
junctions
now all these molecules are actually
linking
to the cytoskeletal element on either
sides of the cells and thereby forming a
very tight junction which don't even
allow a small molecule to pass through
and thereby the selectivity filter is
created
and this
creates the stringency in terms of
passage of certain molecules from the
blood to the brain
now let me tell you that blood brain
barrier is implicated in many diseases
such as
als
epilepsy brain trauma and many other
neurodegenerative diseases as well
now one thing we should understand at
this point that not all the vessels in
the human brain exhibit blood brain
barrier like properties
in fact in choroid plexus in the
circumventure organ there are blood
vessels which are somewhat leaky
so here i'm going to introduce two
terminologies blood brain barrier and
blood csf barrier
the idea between both this barrier is to
prevent entry of harmful substances into
the brain
but the difference exists between these
two barriers blood brain barrier is a
endothelial barrier whereas the blood
csf barrier is a epithelial barrier so
it really matters where is the tide
junction located here the type junction
is located in the endothelial cell in
case of blood-brain barrier whereas it
is situated in the
epithelial cells in case of blood csf
barrier in order to know more about
blood csf barrier you can click on the
video which is in the eye button but
this video pretty much summarize the
structure anatomy and the functions of
blood
brain barrier
you can get a notes in my facebook page
the link is provided in the description
so don't forget to check it out anyway
don't forget to like share and subscribe
support my channel and patreon
my courses are present in academy which
is india's biggest online learning
platform using my code ap10 you can get
a 10 discount if you wish to connect to
me
you can follow me on several social
media and for see you in next time